Why would anybody peel a carrot when they
could use an oversized pencil sharpener built
just for them?
And the same goes for cigarette...pencils.
It's episode 27 of LÜT.
For pencils that are more musical, grab yourself
a pair of drumstick pencils.
And David Bizer records the waveform of a
word or phrase you speak and then makes this,
whose pieces you can pop out to make your
own waveform into a necklace.
He's also published instructions on how to
make your own for free.
Now, brass knuckles are a more useful form
of jewellery, especially when you upgrade
to the kind that's also a taser.
Projectile defences improve by using a target
dummy, so you better choose the bleeding zombie
target.
This brain-eater will actually bleed when
hit.
You can rub it in by wearing a Kentucky Fried
Brains t-shirt or this one, which reminds
all of us that zombies ar...were people too.
Now keep your hair tidy with periodic table
barrettes and make some customized art right
away with myDaVinci[.com].
With one click you can personalize and order
prints just the way you want them.
Now, while photos and lockets are romantic,
this Mystery Science Theatre 3000 frame pendant
makes whatever photo you put in it that much
more hilarious.
Stay safe and bright with monkey lights, a
brilliant array of LEDs for your bike tires
that can display patterns while you ride.
If it's a chilly bike ride you're taking,
be sure to wear these matching lobster gloves
and hat.
Food time.
Use this mold to bake a 1-up cupcake and decorate
food with goggly eyes, that you can eat.
Season the rest of your food with some salt
and pepper shakers gnome butt.
Or if you feline like it, use these shakers
that look like cat butts.
Now, cats also love couches,
so get yourself a cat tunnel couch.
If you've upgraded from a cat to baby, don't
carry it like a square.
Stick your kid in a baby holster like a real cowboy.
You know, like the kind that ride on dogs.
Feeling handy?
Paint the house with electrically conductive
paint and install this power-up plate on top
of your switches to control your lights with
buttons and a joystick.
You can install the whole thing with a handgun drill.
And then go to the hardware store to cut this
rude key into something useful.
The labyrinth aquarium is a mansion for sealife,
but don't count out owning this one you can
fill with actual jellyfish they sell you.
Even scarier is a jack-o'-lantern with pumpkin
teeth.
Your pumpkin will feel beautiful.
So next, raise your own self-esteem by using
self deprecating golf balls from TheCheeky[.com].
They contain phrases like "we both know that
shot was my fault."
Tetris is kind of like putting together a
puzzle, which makes this a puzzle puzzle.
ThinkGeek[.com] offers a pack of 566 digit magnets,
which you can use to spell things out like
an old calculator, but on your fridge, which
might contain soda bottles.
But why not replace them with Vat19[.com]'s
giant cola gummies?
The only thing more luxurious is a slide for
your yacht, which you, of course, captain
while wearing a pair of 24 carat gold-dipped
NIKE's, while sipping tea brewed with your
TIE fighter Death Star infuser.
But don't do these things alone.
Be watched by these ominous security cameras,
that are actually a lamp.
In this notebook, your doodles and scribblings
become automatic tattoo art.
And even trash can be useful.
Like these playing cards Metrodeck makes out
of discarded subway cards.
Your furniture can contain optical illusions,
like these cracked cabinets or perspective
curtains that close off a room while presenting
what looks like lies behind them.
Here's a table that is a bad dog.
And the glass sides of this chair make it
look impossibly balanced from the side.
In the same way that letters on the street
are elongated, so you can read them from a
shallow angle,
so are the numbers on Tokyoflash's newest watch.
From above, it looks like almost nothing.
And, of course, because Tokyoflash is so saucy,
using code VSTF gets you $10 off.
All of those things are really cool and you
could find out more by clicking links in this
video's description.
Of course, Vsauce also has a Facebook page,
a Twitter page and as they say in Poland...
Jak zawsze, dziękujemy za oglądanie.
[And as always, thanks for watching.]
Vsauce cupcakes!